six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller we'll try
the six one seven number again I don't
know what happened before six one seven
are you with us hello hi go ahead okay
um so recently Charlie Baker's son was
there's allegations that he had groped
someone on an airplane and there's a lot
of secrecy around that like I learned
the investigation the police are like
refusing to release information about it
and I was wondering what do you think
about it and do you think it will affect
Charlie Baker I have this is the first
I've heard of it Pat have you heard
about this story about you saw the
headline do you so how old is Charlie
Baker's son do you know um I don't he's
gonna he's definitely an adult but I
don't know how old probably around 30
yeah I have not heard about this I think
that his privileged position is the son
of the Massachusetts governor should not
impact the investigation the
investigation should happen in the exact
same way that it would happen no matter
who it was I do I have reason to think
it's not going to happen that way not
particularly but I would want to make
damn sure that this is a fair
investigation I don't think it will
impact Charlie Baker Charlie Baker you
know Republican governor of a relatively
blue state Massachusetts generally not
an unpopular guy and unless the
allegations escalate into something
worse I don't think it will affect
Charlie Baker all right thank you all
right thanks no thanks for the call yeah
I just had not heard about that story
but I will I will look and look into it